[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
y mire
[Música]
e
sí
[Música]
y
débil
[Música]
enero
i
e
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
muy buenas tardes como veis hoy no ve ni
un sola me acompaña no solo mi compañero
de escenario sino también de vida mi
gran amigo además aris podido apreciar
que tengo unas manos son tanto
peculiares lo que comúnmente se conoce
como una discapacidad física que
confesaros que odio muy pocas cosas en
este mundo y que esta palabra sea a
veces traducida como una característica
peligrosa e incluso monstruosa por
algunas personas me duele y de hecho con
ocho años una compañera de clase me
deseo la muerte por este motivo y diréis
bueno es una niña y por eso mismo los
niños son esponjas absorben lo que
aprenden de su entorno
y por eso estoy aquí porque esos niños
se convierten en los adultos que educan
a una sociedad futura yo hoy os voy a
compartir como con tres ingredientes
estoy en un camino hacia la metamorfosis
de mi gran versión el primero de ellos
es la disciplina como en cualquier otra
área la disciplina marca la diferencia
el camino hacia el éxito y diréis vale
pues como en cualquier otra área
yo puedo meterme el empujón pues noches
antes no con una lata de red bull o una
taza de café a la de los apuntes aquí en
las buenas noches en vela así que seamos
sinceros yo sí yo he hecho muchas veces
y en el caso de la música me creaba pues
salir de mi zona de confort a patadas
porque somos como los atletas
necesitamos de un fondo para no llegar a
un punto de dolor y de lesión no en
romper esta barrera física día a día no
subir como pequeños escaloncitos son los
que hace que un día esos sueños se
conviertan en
en realidad y también en este camino y
te encuentras momentos que no crees en
ti porque decir bueno es fácil si lo
dices pero luego haciéndolo claro pero
pongo las manos en el fuego que si tú
terminas creando no creando sino
creyendo eso es lo que luego terminas
creando no y yo mi doctor me dijo andrew
nunca vas a poder tocar un instrumento
pero no le creía y ahora toco 3
sin embargo un día están en el metro en
madrid un señor un estaba pidiendo
dinero porque está en paro y él decía
que el principal motivo era este porque
su mano era diferente
y aquí vemos como nosotros somos quienes
decidimos si nuestros monstruos van a
ser aquel colchón por si fracasamos la
excusa perfecta o aquello que nos haga
brillar
así yo decido que para una vida que
tengo no la voy a pasar en el backstage
yo venir aquí a crear mi propia historia
no voy a dejar que otra persona toque el
instrumento por mí
porque sería fácil
y cuando realmente tú decides hacerlo
por ti te das cuenta que no solamente es
eso en ti es decir también llevas al
resto de personas porque van a tener
focos en lo que sí depende de ti la
gente lo ve y muchas veces cuando estoy
con una agrupación tocando pues claro yo
mi parte trabajada y a veces pues podría
llegar más rápido a la siguiente pero
cuando lo compartes con las personas y
vas a un resultado más bonito un diálogo
musical personas diferentes creando
emociones muy bonitas y claro este sueño
es es muy guay pero si no empiezas en ti
pues no ya lo decía gandhi no sé el
cambio que quieres ver en el mundo y
muchas veces hay estímulos externos muy
tentadores micras estrella para los
viernes mis amigos ya me tienen hasta el
moño de mí
no puedo pensar pero tú decides que
prioriza si tus sueños tus objetivos o
estos límites sociales físicos o
mentales
cuando haces esto priorizar lo tuyo la
vida te da un regalo y diréis pues tengo
cuidado porque yo no he visto nada
y señores y señoras hemos llegado al
segundo ingrediente esta metamorfosis
que es la confianza y el trabajo de dos
formas la primera agradeciendo
agradeciendo que mis padres se pueden
permitir económicamente mi propio cello
mis clases pero vamos más allá agradecer
la respiración por ejemplo algo que
todos compartimos
yo lo interiorizado desde muy pequeña
porque el cordón umbilical se me enredó
en manos y pies cuando perfectamente
pudo haber sido en el cuello
y así es como la vida cuando confías en
ella te lo muestra pero no solamente es
en estas cosas normales sino en cosas
más allá en que el universo está conmigo
y no contra mí que cuando me pone una
situación de dificultad es porque quiere
que saque lo mejor de mí y aprovechando
que estamos en tierra de vinos cómo se
hace estrujando la uva
pasa lo mismo con las personas
y en la vida nos base nos harán más
ejemplos por ejemplo que se nos rompa
nuestros zapatos favoritos
eso es que tanto yo nos había costado o
que la persona que nos gustaba no
sufrían sonido es decir solo quiere una
relación amistad con nosotros
y muchos planes también por ejemplo con
lakovic fueron suspendidos pero vamos a
buscarle
otra solución la vuelta la tortilla y
los zapatos siguientes que me compré
pues es mejor no ir en una relación en
el que una persona del cien por cien de
ella mientras que la otra pues éste por
ella por lástima
y con el que yo viví muchas situaciones
de tener que cancelar conciertos viajes
nueve meses sin pisarlo de hecho pero
deciros que no cambio por nada y cuando
digo nada es absolutamente nada la
sensación que produjo el volver a ellos
ese crujir del escenario esas miradas de
entre los compañeros o el calor del
aplauso del público fue precioso
y en
en esto
viene a ser que nosotros decidimos
también sin pensar en positivo sin
pensar que el camino de no amargarnos
sino de ser felices que es el que yo
elijo es el que nos va a hacer agradecer
todo y muchas veces yo cuando estoy con
ellos me para pensar y digo
tío qué guay osea que en situaciones en
las que me pongo a prueba y confiando en
que todo va a seguir perfecto aunque yo
me ponga esos límites mentales a veces
comparándome o viendo situaciones de
frustración en el que no sé qué decisión
tomar porque infravaloró y caigo en la
comparación pero esas situaciones no yo
pasé por tres bachilleratos diferentes
fijaros si me costó decidir pero cuando
confías en que ha sido así agradeces
esos bachilleratos esas personas que
conociste y te das cuenta que era la
puerta correcta que va perfecto así
y eso es lo que me hace estar aquí a día
de hoy y decidir
lo interiorizado lo comprendo no son
simples palabras y me siento mejor y me
coloco en el medio y puedo decirte que
si yo puedo tú también
y ahora hemos llegado al tercer
ingrediente que es el amor el más
importante diría yo he comenzado con la
palabra o mejor dicho que la canción
salita que viene a ser un saludo de amor
y es porque así fue como comenzó mi vida
mis padres ejemplo de amor incondicional
que tengo ellos vieron cómo me
diferencia una bendición
y me enseñaron verlos como mi gran
virtud y no una cruz
además en el camino me encontrado con
personas que bueno tiene una
discapacidad en soledad también similar
a la mía y ellos no han llegado a ese
punto el motivo suele ser que no han
recibido este saludo de amor
y diréis bueno y qué puedo hacer yo ante
eso
pues cuando veas una situación
pues que puede ser el inicio de un
bullying de un acoso o
[Música]
desde infravalorarse depresión
no te pongas una venda no te la pongas
además os voy a comentar algo que
descubierto cuando tengo una primera
conversación en una persona que
desconozco yo me
[Música]
me he fijado en que hay como tres
patrones que suelen seguir el primero de
ellos y menos habitual es que bueno me
preguntan directamente voy a andar y
aquí te paso en las manos y yo es súper
entusiasmada les respondo que es verán
una sonrisa en la cara y me gusta porque
es como que guay quieren saber más de mí
la segunda es también muy bonita y es
cuando directamente es algo que no se
subraya porque se ve como natural y
surge en la conversación y la tercera en
la cual me voy a centrar porque es la
que más ocurre es que deciden no
preguntarme porque yo no me siento
incómoda y yo siempre me quedo con el
pensamiento de perón a molestar algo que
tengo aceptado de mí como el hecho de
ser morena y que además me han puesto
situaciones que han forjado el andrea
que soy a día de hoy forma parte de mi
identidad y lo amo
estáis en el lado de que estéis yo os
invito a que uséis la bandera del amor
del amor y del respeto
yo me encontraba con dos situaciones a
lo largo de mi vida que sí creo que os
pueden chocar bastante una fue cuando
una amiga me comentaba una situación con
su padre y yo me prisa digo pero como te
voy a contestar o sea me sentía pobre de
consejos porque no lo vivido mis propias
carnes y me dijo andrea que no nos pasa
nada porque yo solamente quiero sentirme
escuchada sin un juicio
la siguiente chica también con una mano
diferente fue muy emotivo porque no
hicieron falta más de 10 minutos de
reloj cuando eso parecía las cataratas
del niágara empatía en estado puro
estos momentos aportando un granito de
arena a la vía a los demás contribuyendo
y
silvia de realizado sintiendo que has
descubierto qué es aquello que tienes
que ofrecer al mundo
es decir
es este sabes cómo te paras a pensarlo
es este el motivo por el que estoy aquí
es mi propósito y ya muchas veces nos
centramos también en dar en dar y dar y
dar y dar y no nos damos a nosotros
mismos reformulaba pregunta qué ocurrirá
cuando un día te pida nuevas y tú no
tengas uvas que dar el sí está el orden
del día el recto con a se trata de una
misma esto es un gran error y así es
como define mi primer año universitario
estaba lleno de experiencias
maravillosas y yo concluyó para siento
pues va aportó a todos pero llega un
punto que que te das cuenta que aunque
no lo cambiaría por nada del mundo en
realidad se trataban de partes yo
realmente lo que hacía era encontrar
algo que se igualará a lo que la música
me hace sentir
el primer paso es darse cuenta
lo siguiente es tener coraje coraje para
darte el seattle coraje para dejar de
vivir la vida perfecta que otros han
diseñado para ti coraje para despertarte
cada mañana y subir esos pequeños
escalones que separen la distancia de
tus sueños y la realidad
vive obsesionado en el camino y enfócate
en lo que sí depende de ti
evita al universo aquí estoy
perfectamente empeñada y con los brazos
abiertos para abrazar aquello que tengas
preparado para mí
por igual porque es grande el como viene
solo
y sobre todo no permitas que tus miedos
sean más grandes que tus sueños
adéntrate
pero bien trate de llano
sin maquillaje desnudo a tu metamorfosis
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aquí
[Música]